This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. A few years after the communist revolution brought Mao Zedong to power, China's leader ordered his people to exterminate four pests, rats, flies, mosquitoes, and sparrows. The birds were eating China's grain. Chairman Mao had recently collectivized agriculture, and he wanted to kill off the birds consuming his country's food. During the Great Sparrow campaign, as the effort was called, millions of birds were killed. People shot sparrows or banged on pots and pans until the birds fell to the ground in exhaustion.
But the eradication of the sparrows produced an unintended consequence. Insect populations soared because one of their natural predators had been eliminated. Locusts swept across China's fields, decimating crops, and contributing to a great famine. Official figures put the death toll at 15 million people. Unofficial numbers were 2-5 times higher. While the scale of the disaster was unimaginable, China is hardly alone when it comes to wrong-headed policies. From nations and governments to companies and families, humans regularly fail to foresee how initiatives can backfire. This week, we continue our series, Success 2.0,
with a look at one of the principle sources of failure in our lives. Unint unintended consequences. How to expect the unexpected when we plan for the future, this week on Hidden Brain. Much of life is about getting others to behave in the way we want. We come up with carrots and sticks to persuade children to do their homework, prompt partners to pick up their socks, and motivate co-workers to do their best. But often these inducements are ineffective. Sometimes they even backfire.
Uri Gnese is an economist at the University of California, San Diego. He studies how we craft incentives and smart ways to do it better. Uri Ignezi, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, great to be here. Uri, when you were a child growing up in Tel Aviv in Israel, the heroes of Israeli society were the fighter pilots who served in Israel's Air Force. When you were 11 or 12 years old, you heard a story about these fighter pilots that made quite an impression on you. Tell me that story.
So in Israel being a fighter pilot was the highest social status you can have and everyone wanted to be one, including me. So think about Top Gun on steroids. And my hobby was to read all these World War II books and other books about fighter pilots going out and shooting down enemy airplanes and becoming heroes. And so I remember this story that I read about the six day war. It was a mirage pilot that told the story. He was there with his three buddies.
The four planes were looking for Egyptian mix over the told the story. He was there with his three buddies. The four planes were looking for Egyptian MiGs over the Suez Canal, and suddenly he saw two of them in the horizon, and they turned immediately over there. His friends didn't see where he went, and they asked him, and he said, that he just is chasing the MiGs to the west, when he actually chased them to the east. And basically what he did was trying to get
these MiGs by himself, to shoot them to the east. And basically what he did was trying to get this mix by himself, to shoot them down by himself. Now, if he worried about the country and safety and the chance of actually doing this, he would have called his buddies to join him because that's much better. But no, he really wanted to shoot them down by himself. So he lied to them and he was after that, he was very proud of it.
So that shows that the incentives are really working in this case in it might be a funny way, but I remember like you said when I was 11 or 12 thinking about okay so that's the real incentive, that's what motivates him, that's what gets this guy to go and risk his life because he really wanted the social status that came up with shooting down the meeks. So it's interesting, you know, the very high status awarded to pilots, you could say that that's a good thing for a country to be doing because, of course, by recognizing soldiers and pilots, the country basically incentivizes people to want to join the armed forces and to protect the country.
But what you're showing here is that that incentive now can actually change people's behavior in ways that actually don't serve the best interests of the country. Right, you get the best people to actually want and to go out and shoot enemy planes risk in their life. But in some cases, it can really make you do stupid things. Because now your motivation is not completely aligned with the organization.
The organization in this case, the state of Israel wanted the mix to be shut down and you to be safe. So sometime later when you were a teenager, you and your classmates knocked on doors each year to raise money for charity. And when your teachers came up with an incentive to get kids to do a better job, tell us how the charity program worked, what kind of activities you did each year with your friends, and what the incentive was that teachers came up with that one year. So when I grew up in Israel, we used to go out a few times a year to collect money for
charities like the Cancer Association or Kids in Danger. And together with another 15, 16-year-old kid, you went around knocked on doors and tried to raise money. Now, it was really, you didn't have to persuade the donors because they knew exactly what it is. And the more doors you knocked on, the more success you had. And I remember as a kid that I was very happy when I got to the age when I could participate in this. And my friend and I went out and tried to knock on as many doors. We got receipts for 500 shakles, which was about $780 at a time. But then there were also some kids who
didn't do anything. They just didn't go. And the teacher came up with the brilliant incentive scheme. She said, if you raise at least 100 shakles, then you won't have to do homework over the weekend. And it worked. So it was a brilliant incentive in the sense that now everyone went out and collected at least 100 shakles. But actually, many of us, including me, stopped now at 100 shakles.
And as a result, what happened is more kids actually went out, but the overall collection was much smaller than before. So in some ways, the incentive was trying to change the behavior of the weakest performers, and in fact, it successfully did so, but at the cost of undermining the performance of the strongest performers. Exactly, and overall performance as well. One last example I want to touch on, years later after you became a parent yourself, you once took your son to Disney World and you spotted a sign setting out
the ticket prices for admission to the park. What did the sign say, Uri? So the sign said, if you're under three year old, it's free. Over three year old, it's $117. Now, my son just turned three a couple of months earlier, and I loved that period because he started communicating. You can talk with him, it's a lot of fun. But they also start lying when they start talking.
That's also very, very human, right? And of course, as parents, we told him that he shouldn't lie, only bad kids lie. So we got to the counter and then I saw that if the kid is under three, it's free. And the Kashir asked me, you know, how old is your kid? I looked at him and I said, well, it's almost three. Now, it wasn't a lie completely because it was almost three but from the wrong direction, but you know, a lie and got to pay whatever. And then we started walking and about half an hour later my son pulled my shirt and said,
Daddy, Daddy, you told me that only bad people lie and now you just lied, right? And of course I turned pale and my reaction was something of the sort of, do as I say and not as I do. A few minutes later, we got to another attraction and this one was, my son, Ron, really wanted to do it, but it turns out that you needed to be at least for, you know, to be able to go on it. And Ron, without hesitation, said, yeah, I'm for. And, you know, turns out that what you actually learned
was not to do as I say, but to do as I do. So you saved $117 on Ron's ticket, but the price was that you sent your three-year-old kid the message that lying is okay. Exactly. And I guess the question to us then is, is that the right price to pay, you know, for the message that you were sending your kid? I think that that's exactly the question. So when you do something like that, you need to think, is it worth $1,7 billion in order
to send this message? In some cases, you might say yes, but in retrospect, no, it wasn't. I wouldn't have done it again. In retrospect, now it wasn't. I wouldn't have done it again. Classical economics presents us with a very simple understanding of incentives. Incentives can get people to do things they might not otherwise do. Once an incentive is introduced, people's motivation will
increase as you increase the size of the reward. But the way incentives play out in real life is considerably more complicated. When we come back, we peel back the layers of the incentives onion to understand why it's so hard to get other people to do what we want. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Uri Gneese works at the University of California San Diego. When he was being trained as an economist, he was taught that incentives were simple and straightforward.
Paysam wanted to do something, they'll do it. The more you pay them, the harder they'll work. But over many years of experience and research, URI has come to see that reality is a lot more complicated. URI, I'm wondering if we could start with the basics. What is an incentive and what kind of signal is a design to send? So incentive is something that will motivate you to do
an activity or produce something or whatever, that you wouldn't do without it. And one of the problems with setting incentives is that many people don't understand that these incentives are not just giving you some kind of material payoff, they also send you a signal about what's important for me. And this signal is something that can really impact behavior. So poorly crafted incentives can backfire in that they can actually discourage people
from doing things you want them to do, but it's sometimes hard to tell when an incentive is poorly crafted. For example, we all know that it's nice to say thank you when someone does something nice for us, but the social scientist George Newman and Jeremy Shen once looked at the effect of thank you gifts on charitable contributions.
Tell me what they found, Uri. So they found that if you give people a gift after a 10-q gift, say a coffee mug, it can actually backfire and get people to donate less. And I think that the reason is that it basically changes the meaning of what you're doing, turning the situation into some kind of exchange. Now, I'm not doing it because I'm a nice guy, I'm doing it because I want this bag or pen or whatever the gift is. And then I say, well, I'm not going to spend $100 on this pen or this bag.
It's not worth it. It completely changes the way I perceive the interaction. And because of that, I want to do the activity even less than before. So sending unclear or contradictory signals can change the way people think about a particular situation. And in some ways, it can lead them to engage in behavior that is the opposite of what you're trying to encourage. There's a somewhat related story involving
the Welsh government, officials wanted to crack down on parents who pull kids out of school for family vacations, presumably, officials wanted to crack down on parents who pull kids out of school for family vacations, presumably the policymakers wanted to keep kids in class, so they could learn more, right? Right, so anyone who had kids and wanted to go on vacation knows that that's the worst time to go. So when you have breaks from school, that's where everything is more crowded, more expensive, less pleasant. And some parents decided, you know what, we'll take our kids off school, say a week before or a week after the spring break.
That way we'll save money and we'll have a nice vacation because it's going to be less crowded. The government didn't want to do it, and it introduced a small find. I believe it was 60 pounds if you did that. Now, the situation that the parents faced was very different. Before that, it was, look, the teachers are not going to like it. The principal is not going to like it. Good parents won't do that. Now the story is, oh, if we'll do that, it's 60 pounds. You put a price
on this activity. And now instead of being immoral, now it's like, well, for 60 pounds, I can save much more money by going a week earlier and turns out that many parents decided to do it and some travel agencies even offered to pay this fine for people. Oh my God. Because it was so much better to do it this way, right? It's, everyone is happier apart from the schools that were less happy. One of the things that's tricky about incentives is that in any situation, there is often more
than one motivator at play. So an incentive can amplify one source of motivation, but sometimes they're the expense of something else, and that something else might actually be more important. Uri once saw this play out in British professional soccer where a team was awarding bonuses to individual players for every goal they scored. As a soccer player, there are different ways to motivate you to incentivize you. One of them is just peer your salary, another one pay your pervictory, another one is per scoring a goal.
Or for a assist if you send a ball to someone else. So there was a situation in which if you scored a goal, you got 75,000 pounds. If you sent an assist that ended up in a goal, you got 20,000 pounds. Now imagine that you're facing two options. One option is to try and run yourself and score yourself, say that you have 50% chance of succeeding, then you have 50% chance of getting 75,000 pounds. Or you can send it to your friend and say that your friend has 75% chance of scoring it.
So now you'll get lower than if you try yourself. So in other words, passing the ball might end up getting you less, will get you less money than trying to score yourself even though the odds of you scoring are actually lower than if you pass the ball. Exactly. So now the team clearly cares about scoring the goal. They don't care who's going to do it. They want to win.
That's what the coach and management try to incentivize. And I'm sure that the coach told everyone all the players, look, we are a team, we want you to be a team player and blah blah all the good stuff. But the signal that the incentive said was very different than the signal that the coach told them before. Now, it's a complicated situation because in some cases, if you want to attract the best players in the world, if you want to attract the messy of the world, you really need to pay them a lot per success, right? But at least don't send a message telling them that you care about team game and incentivize individual success. That's not going to work. This is a little bit like the story of the Israeli pilot, which is the Israeli pilot cared
about more about his own glory than about what was actually best for the country. Exactly, and still, I'm not saying that that's necessarily a bad incentive because these incentives really motivate the fighter pilot and the soccer player to do their best, but in some cases it could create a problem. So it's also the case that in group settings, different people often have competing incentives. Oory, I want to play you a clip from the TV show Friends. This scene is unfolding at a restaurant. And for the gentleman, yeah, I'll have the Thai chicken pizza, miss.
OK, I will have the side salad. And for you? I'm going to have a cup of the side salad. And for you? I'm going to have a cup of the cucumber soup. I will have the Cajun catfish. Everyone enjoys that meal. Then the bill arrives. OK, everyone owes $28. Everyone?
No, no way. Sorry, not going to happen. Rachel just had that. So Uri, you've talked about a problem known as the unscrupulous diners dilemma. What is this dilemma? So, I love this clip from friends. Basically, what happens is that if you know that you're going to split the bill, then what the economy is called, your marginal cost goes down. So, imagine that there are five people in the restaurant and we're going to split the bill.
So if I spend another $10 on my main dish, I will actually pay only $2 out of that because the other people are going to pay the rest. So then my calculation becomes very different. If before that I would say, well, the lobster cost $50, I don't want to spend that much. Now I say, well, the lobster will actually cost me only $10. I should go for it, right?
That's my chance. And that's indeed what we found in our experiment. We brought students to actual restaurant. And we saw what happened when we told them that we're going to split the bill versus when we told them that each one will pay for themselves. So they ordered more, they ordered the drinks suddenly. They were real festive. And by the way, they ordered the drinks suddenly, they were
real festive. And by the way, it was true for men and women. The entire bill was so much higher when they split the bill that it was funny to see. In many cases, restaurants will say, if you're a group bigger than X, we want you to actually split the bill. And that could be one of the motivations. They know that people order more when they split the bill and that could be one of the motivation. They know that people order more when they split the bill. Now, we've looked at how incentives are designed to send signals, but of course, the signals we're sending are not being heard by computers or robots. They're being heard by human beings. And human beings don't just respond to the signal. They ask, what is this signal really about? What is it telling me? During the COVID pandemic, or some states like Ohio decided to encourage their citizens to get vaccinated
using a rather unusual incentive. Tell me what they did. So they offered a lottery that will give you, say, a million dollar. Some of them were even higher than that. So they're going to go to all the people that got vaccinated this week and one of them is going to get a million dollar in a lottery. Which is great, you know, it's nice, what can go wrong. So here's a thought experiment. Imagine that someone invites you to join a test for a new drug. They tell you that's a headache, a pill that you can take and your headache will go away and there are no side effects that we know and we'll pay you $50 for participating. They tell you that's a headache, a pill that you can take and your headache will go away. And there are no side effects that we know and will pay you $50 for participating.
That's basically what the FDA does in many cases and I think that it makes sense to do. And I would be willing to take part in such a study. Now imagine that it's the same but they tell you will pay you $50,000 for participating. Now I'll be worried, right? If there are no side effects, why are there offering me so much money to take this one pill? And I think that this signal that if you're paying me a million dollar to get vaccinated,
it must be really bad for me to get vaccinated, right? Because otherwise, why do you have to pay me to do it? Yeah. Remember that we talked about completing the story. This completes the story in a different way than you intended. You wanted to tell him, look, I care about you so much, then I'm willing to pay you because it's so important.
And the bad things that can happen are so bad that I want to encourage you. That was your story, but the story that the people may hear is that this is actually bad for you. It's so bad that we are willing to pay your million dollar to do it. Another dimension of incentives that makes them tricky has to do with the fact that the people we're trying to influence
perceive not just a carrot, but also a stick. So when people don't achieve an objective, they start to ask, what's going to happen if I fail? Uri, tell me what happened at Wells Fargo Bank in the early 2000s when they introduced an incentive to increase performance. So the CEO had a greater idea. I want every customer that we have to have at least
eight products from the bank. So if the customer has, say, a checking account, I wanted to also have a credit card and saving account and whatever. And they gave very strong incentives for the people working in the bank to actually do that. And actually, if you did not meet the goals that they gave, it's not only that you didn't get the incentives, you were also very likely to be fired because your colleagues were able to do it. Now turns out that it's very hard to do it. And the way the colleagues were able to do it. Now, turns out that it's very hard to do it, and the way the colleagues were able to do it
is by making up accounts. So, you know, think about the image of a worker coming to the bank in the morning, drinks is or her coffee, sit down at the computer, and start making up fake accounts. According to authorities, inside Wells Fargo, employees called it gaming, forging customer
signatures, creating pins to activate unauthorized debit cards, and moving money to unauthorized accounts. I had 15 accounts at once. It was just very frustrating. And these were accounts I never opened. And it wasn't one or two people. We're talking about over 3 million accounts, and they fired at the end over 5,000 people for doing this. So basically the CEO wanted to have more products, very account,
got exactly what he wanted. The stock of Wells Fargo went up. Everything was fine. Apart from the fact that it was all ballooned, it was clearly going to explode at one point because it was all fake. I'm wondering if part of the problem here, Uri, is that the leaders were trying to incentivize an explicit behavior, which is to aggressively sell the company's products. But they ignored how this incentive might affect other behaviors, including the implicit norm to be honest. They probably weren't thinking at the point they set up the incentive program, well what happens when people don't meet this target? What are they going to do? So given people incentives to create extra account is not bad in itself. It will work.
People will try harder, but at the same time they're to put some safety measures that will make sure that people don't lie. So when you design incentives like this, think about how can people try and game the incentive? Because that's what we do. We game the incentives all the time. That's where we are very good at it. We are very creative at it. So for example, if there was enough auditing done, and once you catch someone making up an account,
you immediately fired that person, that would have worked. But instead, what happened is that even whistleblower that came to the management said, this is happening, they were actually fired. So the incentive in itself wasn't bad, it just lacked the safety measure that was needed. You cite a revealing incident from colonial era Vietnam. French authorities were confronting a problem and they came up with a solution.
It involved incentivizing ordinary people to go out and kill rats, but that incentive ended up producing a problem of its own. Tell me what happened, Dury. So the French wanted to introduce toilets to Hanoi, which is very French of them to do. And when the toilets were introduced, they also need sewage. And with sewage come the rats. So there was a big problem with rats, and the authorities were very smart.
They said, let's pay, say, 10 cents per rat tail that you bring. So there was a poor guy in the city hall that was counting rat tails. And for each one of them he gave ten cents. That sounds again like a very good incentive that what can go wrong that's you give the people you let the people go after the rats everything's going to be well. Well turns out for example that people just cut the tail of the rat and let the rat go free because the rat can can have more babies that way. Some of them started the rat and let the rat go free because the rat can have more babies that way. Some of them started the rat farms, so they started raising their own rats in order to
harvest their tails. Some of them brought rats from neighboring cities in order to cut their tails. So again, people are really good at gaming the incentives and you need to find a way and incentives that actually is robust to such manipulation. You know, it's interesting because I think this draws attention to the fact that when you're leading a company or a city or a country, you know, it's very easy to focus on something that is not going well and come up with a simple plan to fix that thing, but the problematic thing usually doesn't exist in a vacuum. It's connected to other things or it can influence things one layer beneath the surface.
And in some ways, I think what all these examples are pointing to is the complexity of human behavior and perhaps how we need to exercise a certain amount of humility when it comes to trying to engineer that behavior. So when I work with companies very often I hear some version of we tried incentives and they didn't work and when I hear this I think about you know someone went to a bad Japanese restaurant and his or her conclusion is Japanese food is bad. No that's not the right conclusion you went to a bad restaurant and the same is true about incentives it's not that incentives don't work it's just that you and the same is true about incentives. It's not that incentives don't work.
It's just that you didn't understand the complexity of incentives. Incentives are powerful tools. They can make people act in ways they would not have left to their own devices, but misunderstood or misapplied incentives can backfire and boomerang. When we come back, how to craft incentives that get yourself and others moving in the direction of success. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Economist Uri Gnese is the author of Mixed Signals, how incentives really work.
He studies the science of how we use carrots and sticks to get others to behave the way we want. Uri, when someone crafts an incentive, the people being incentivized, use the signal of the incentive to draw conclusions about the sender. So poorly designed or poorly presented incentives can backfire by making the creator of the incentive, localis or greedy. You recently observed this in an initiative launched by a movie theater chain. Can you tell me what happened? So recently AMC decided to have different prices for different seats.
They understood that people don't like to sit up front or on the sides. Their solution was, let's raise the price for the middle seats, for the premium seat, and that's what airlines are doing, that's what hotels are doing. But the way they did it really created a pushback. Many people were upset. The prices are already so high, and now your charging are more for the premium seats, that's really an nasty behavior. That's the story that people heard. But instead of that,
Amc could have said, look, we're sorry, the prices are so high, the inflation, whatever, we need to raise our prices, we're sorry, but here's the good news, we're going to give you discount if you're willing to sit in the first row or on the sides. So exactly the same incentives, but frame them, tell the story, fill up the story in a way that instead of I'm greedy and want to take even more money from you, is the story that you're telling is, look, we're trying to help you and we're offering this discount on less desirable seats. So in other words, let's say for example, the ticket prices were $10 and you're charging $15 for the premium seats.
What you're saying is, you know, raise the ticket prices to $15 for everyone and then basically make the less attractive seats discounted to $10. It comes to the same thing, but the story becomes completely different. Exactly. Exactly. Instead of I'm taking advantage of you whenever I can, it's I'm trying to help you whenever I can.
I had to raise prices because everything costs more. We have to pay more for our workforce. We have to pay more for rent. So we had to do this, but we really care about the people that have hard time paying, and we really want them to actually keep coming. So this point of course to the importance of paying attention not just to the incentive, but the story that the incentive is communicating.
Some companies have found a way to use incentives to tell a consistent story about their values and you say that one such company is the sandwich chain, Prada Mangi. How do they design incentives, Yuri? So they wanted to give you some kind of bonus like employer of the week or something like that and give you a bonus. Now, in every case that you're doing something like this, you're actually doing something else as well. You're also, it's not just the people that you invite to the party, it's also the people that you don't invite that you should care about. So the people that in this case did not get the bonus, in this case the bonus was $50.
有些公司已经找到了利用激励措施来传续其价值观的方法，你说其中一家公司就是三明治连锁店 Prada Mangi。尤里，他们是如何设计激励措施的？所以他们想给你某种奖金，比如“本周员工”之类的奖励。然而，在你做这种事的每一种情况下，其实你也在做别的事情。不仅是你邀请到派对上的人，你也应该关心那些你没有邀请的人。所以在这个案例中没有拿到奖金的人，这里的奖金是50美元。
And the way they thought to reduce the problem was that if you were the employee of the week or the month, you got the $50, but you were asked to spend it on someone else on one of your friends. So the incentive on the surface is designed to reward people for reaching a milestone, but really the way the company is using it, the incentive is designed to enhance team building. Yes, if it's a subjective measure, for example, how well you did on something that we can't measure in dollars, then I'm going to be upset if you'll get the reward because I'm clearly better than you. This way, it reduced by a lot the tension between the employees about who's going to win this. So winning it was, you still got you the status and
他们减少这种问题的方法是，如果你是本周或本月员工，你可以得到50美元，但要求你把它花在其他人身上，花在你的某位朋友身上。因此，表面的激励旨在奖励达到里程碑的人，但实际上公司使用它的方式，是为了增强团队建设。是的，如果这是一个主观的衡量标准，例如你在我们无法用金钱衡量的某件事情上表现得有多好，那么如果你得到了奖励，我会很不高兴，因为我明显比你优秀。通过这种方式，它大大减少了员工之间关于谁会赢得这个奖项的紧张气氛。所以赢得它依然能给你带来地位和
it was nice, you felt good about yourself. But the money you gave to other people. So other people, the workers became more friendly with each other and there was less tension over there. One problem with incentives is that people will change their behavior for as long as they are being incentivized to do so, but will then revert to their previous behavior once the incentive is withdrawn. Your own research, however, has shown that incentives can create long-lasting change if they are used in a particular way. Tell us about your study about building exercise habits. So creating habits is maybe the holy grail of incentives. How can we change your habits? How can we get you to exercise more? Stop smoking or diet better,
感觉很好，你对自己感觉不错。但钱是你给别人的。所以其他人，工人们彼此变得更友好，那里的紧张气氛也减少了。激励措施的一个问题是，人们会在获得激励的期间改变行为，但一旦激励撤销，就会恢复到以前的行为。然而，你自己的研究表明，如果以特定方式使用，激励可以产生持久的改变。给我们讲讲你关于建立锻炼习惯的研究吧。因此，培养习惯可能是激励机制的圣杯。我们如何改变你的习惯？我们如何让你多锻炼？戒烟或更好地节食，
whatever is the activity that you want to do. Turns out to be very difficult, because it's an ongoing behavior which is very hard to change and many of us, those of us that struggle with this including me, remember periods of their life in which they exercise. So there were periods in my life in which I exercise, I was very happy about is going to the gym or surfing or biking, whatever it is. And then I have periods in my life in which I can get myself off the couch. The only physical activity is watching Netflix. What's the difference between these two? And what we thought about, and there is some literature suggesting this, that once you get into the activities, so say for a month, after that, it's much easier. So the first
无论你想做什么活动。结果发现这非常难，因为它是一项持续的行为，很难改变，我们中的许多人，包括我在内都在为此挣扎，还记得他们生命中锻炼过的一段时间。所以我生命中曾有一段时间锻炼过，我去健身房、冲浪或骑自行车，无论做什么，我都为此感到非常高兴。然后我生命中又有一些时期，我无法让自己离开沙发。唯一的体力活动就是看 Netflix。这两者之间有什么区别？我们所思考的，以及一些文献所表明的是，一旦你开始参与这些活动，比如持续一个月，之后就容易多了。所以第一次
time you go to the gym, it smells bad, you don't know where to park, you don't know what to do, it's kind of embarrassing. After a month, suddenly you don't bother to smell that much. And you know exactly what you're going to do. And say, you put it in your schedule, that Monday and Thursday at 9 a.m. I'm going to do yoga classes, whatever it is that you're doing, suddenly it becomes much easier for you. And the idea was that if you can build this,
你去健身房，气味不好，你不知道把车停在哪儿，你不知道该做什么，这有点尴尬。一个月后，突然之间你不再介意气味那么大了。而且你确切知道你要做什么。比如，你把它安排在日程里，周一和周四早上9点我要去上瑜伽课，无论你在做什么，突然间对你来说就容易多了。这个想法是，如果你能建立这个，
if you can invest in this month, even if you're going to suffer, and you think that the suffering is bigger than the benefit, just investing this month, even if you're going to suffer and you think that the suffering is bigger than the benefit, just investing this month and then after that it might become really easier. So we did it with incentive, it was Gary Charnes and I, so we pay students $100 to go to the gym eight times for a month. And then after that we stopped paying them and we saw that the people that got paid to go to the gym were much more likely to go to the gym than the control group. So we did create some kind of habit. Turns out that this habit dies
如果你能投资这个月，即使你会痛苦，而且你认为痛苦大于收益，只需投资这个月，即使你会痛苦，而且你认为痛苦大于收益，只需投资这个月，之后它可能真的会变得更容易。所以我们用激励机制做到了这一点，加里·查恩斯和我，我们付给学生100美元，让他们在一个月内去健身房八次。然后我们停止向他们支付费用，我们发现获得报酬去健身房的人比对照组更有可能去健身房。所以我们确实创造了某种习惯。事实证明，这个习惯消亡得
quite fast. So you know winter break, they come back, the habit is dead. So how to maintain this habit is still a question, but it is interesting that if I can get you over this hurdle of of actually going to the gym for a few times, it's going to be easier. Now, you can also think about it for yourself. You can incentivize yourself. The first time you'll go, like we said, you're going to suffer, but you should commit. I'm going to force myself to go for a month, and only then I'm going to evaluate whether I want to continue or not.
相当快。所以你知道寒假到了，他们回来时，习惯已经消亡了。因此，如何保持这个习惯仍然是个问题，但有趣的是，如果我能让你克服实际上去健身房几次的这个障碍，事情就会变得更容易。现在，你也可以为自己考虑这一点。你可以激励自己。正如我们所说，第一次去的时候你会痛苦，但你应该承诺。我将强迫自己去一个月，只有在那之后，我才会评估自己是想继续还是放弃。
And you might be surprised by the outcome. A related idea is that incentives can also be used to help people get past what you call switching costs. What are these, Yuri? So switching costs is something that we do all the time. So we have this image and going to the supermarket. You know which kind of shampoo you're going to buy or toilet paper. Maybe at the beginning you searched a bit, but then you chose one brand of toilet papers,
你可能会对结果感到惊讶。一个相关的想法是，激励也可以用来帮助人们克服你所谓的转换成本。尤里，这些是什么？转换成本是我们一直在做的事情。所以我们有这种去超市的印象。你知道你要买哪种洗发水或卫生纸。也许一开始你搜索了一会儿，但后来你选择了一个牌子的卫生纸，
and that's what you're taking. Switching to another one will require a standing over there thinking about it, comparing prices, is it soft enough or not, you're not going to do it, you're going to stay with the toilet paper that you know. Now imagine that you go, you reach to your regular toilet paper and you see that the competitor is as a discount, you know, half price, say. Now you're saying, wow, that's a big discount. Let me try the other one. I'll try it. You'll take it, try it. And if you like it, you might switch to it and go back, when you go back, you'll actually search for it because you like it, even if there won't be a discount on it. So there is a switching cost which is, it could be a mental switching cost like that, that you just don't want to think about it. There could be some other switching cost like,
这就是你拿的。换成另一个牌子需要站在那里思考、对比价格、它够不够软等等，你不会去做的，你会继续使用你熟悉的卫生纸。现在想象一下，你走过去，拿到你常用的卫生纸，看到竞争对手在打折，你知道的，比如半价。现在你会说，哇，这是一个大折扣。让我试试另一个。我试试。你会拿它，试一试。如果你喜欢它，你可能会转向它，当你回去时，你实际上会去寻找它，因为你喜欢它，即使它没有折扣。所以存在转换成本，这可能是一种心理上的转换成本，你只是不想去思考它。还可能存在其他转换成本，比如，
imagine now smoking, for example. Imagine that they can actually pay you to stop smoking for a month. Maybe after a month, it's going to be less attractive for you to go back. And that's the idea, right? So switching from one activity to another is costly. If I'll give you a discount, if I'll give you incentives,
现在想象一下吸烟，例如。想象一下，他们真的可以付钱让你戒烟一个月。也许一个月后，你回去的吸引力就会降低。这就是这个想法，对吧？所以从一项活动转换到另一项活动是有成本的。如果我给你折扣，如果我给你激励，
I might get you to change your behavior in a way that you wouldn't do after that. And if I'm lucky, you'll stick with the new behavior later on. In many parts of our lives, we don't see the consequences of our actions until much later. So if you start smoking, for example, it can take years or even decades before you pay the price in terms of health effects. The same thing goes for schooling, but in the opposite direction, it often takes years before you can see the benefits of studying hard and doing while at school.
我可能会让你以一种你平时不会做的方式改变你的行为。如果我很幸运，你以后会坚持这种新行为。在我们生活的许多方面，直到很久以后，我们才看到自己行为的后果。因此，如果你开始吸烟，例如，可能需要几年甚至几十年，你才会为健康影响付出代价。上学也是如此，但方向相反，通常需要几年时间，你才能看到努力学习和在学校表现良好的好处。
You and others have done a lot of thinking about this problem and how incentives might be used to try and improve the performance of students in school. Tell me about this work, Orey. So as a university professor, my life is quite boring, you know, I don't get that many people mad at me unless I go and talk about incentives with educators. That's, you know, they want to kill me. They want to choke me very fast. And I think that they're right in many cases because you want the students to have intrinsic motivation to be successful, right? You don't want to pay the money in order to read books.
你和其他人对这个问题进行了很多思考，以及如何利用激励措施来提高学生在学校的表现。奥雷，跟我讲讲这项工作吧。作为一名大学教授，我的生活挺枯燥的，你知道的，除非我去找教育工作者谈论激励措施，否则不会有那么多人对我生气的。那是，你知道的，他们想杀了我。他们想快点掐死我。我认为他们在很多情况下是对的，因为你希望学生对成功有内在的动机，对吧？你不想为了让他们读书而付钱。
And we know that they can pay you money to read a book. I can't pay you to start enjoying reading the books. So it's much harder, and they sympathize with the teachers and the educator that say this. Or there are things that you can actually use in education that will be useful. So imagine, my example is I write a lot for my living. And yet I write one finger at a time. I don't know how to type. If someone would have paid
我们知道他们可以付钱让你读书。我无法付钱让你开始享受读书的乐趣。所以这难得多，而且我很同情那些这么说的老师和教育工作者。或者有些东西你确实可以用在教育中，并且会很有用。想象一下，我的例子是，我以写作为生。然而我一次只用一根手指打字。我不知道怎么打字。如果有人付给我
me enough money or convinced me to invest a week in learning touch typing, that would be amazing for me. So once you learn the skill, you're not going to go back. And in education, you can think about some landmarks like the data that are important., you're not going to go back. And in education, you can think about some landmarks like did that are important. Imagine you're annoying teenager and the SAT. You understand how important it is. You really want your kid to be successful, but they have other things in mind. If you can find incentives to make sure
足够的钱或者说服我投资一周的时间学习盲打，这对我会非常棒。一旦你学会了这个技能，你就不会再倒退了。在教育中，你可以考虑一些重要的里程碑，比如那些重要的数据。想象一下，你是一个烦人的青少年，还要面对 SAT。你明白它有多重要。你真的希望你的孩子成功，但他们心里有别的事情。如果你能找到激励措施来确保
that they actually prepare well for the SAT, that could still work. The bigger problem, in which I agree with the teachers and the educator is that you cannot use it in order to get kids, students to enjoy what they're doing. That we don't know how to do, and that's much harder. At the same time, it seems like, I think, the picture you're painting here is that incentives are,
他们确实为 SAT 做好了充分准备，这依然管用。更大的问题是，我同意老师和教育工作者的观点，你不能用它来让小孩子、学生享受他们正在做的事情。我们不知道该怎么做，那要难得多。与此同时，看起来，我认为你在这里描绘的画面是，激励是，
perhaps, potentially useful in these narrow, you, the student basically is unable to really comprehend how, you know, applying himself or herself in school can pay off 20 or 30 years down the road. But a carefully targeted incentive can prompt the student to do better on a standardized test, for example, you know, three weeks print, for example. And that might in fact have long-term consequences that are beneficial. That's true, but I wouldn't be that pessimistic
也许，在这些狭窄的领域潜在有用，你，学生基本上无法真正理解，你知道的，在学校里努力学习如何在20或30年后得到回报。但是，一个精心针对的激励可以促使学生在标准化测试中做得更好，例如，考前三周的冲刺。事实上，这可能会产生有益的长期后果。这是真的，但我不会那么悲观
about the first part, because if you use the right incentives, you can make you actually starting more enjoyable. We have a recent paper in which we looked at the effect of physical activity on success, academic success. So imagine that all you care about is the math success in math for the kids. And currently they get 10 hours of math and 2 hours of physical education every week.
关于第一部分，因为如果你使用了正确的激励措施，你可以让学习变得更有趣。我们最近有一篇论文，研究了体力活动对成功、学业成功的影响。假设你唯一关心的是孩子数学方面的成功。目前他们每周上10小时数学课和2小时体育课。
Now you have to cut 2 hours, which one should you cut? Should you cut down the 2 PE classes like most schools do or maybe 2 hours of the math? Even if all you care about is math performance. It could be and that's what we find. We find that students that are engaged in physical activity are actually doing much better academically. So it might be better to take the two hours for math, let them run around and go back and this could be used also as incentives, right? So if you, if I tell you look, finish up the work and you can go out and play some basketball,
现在你必须削减2个小时，你应该削减哪一个？你应该像大多数学校那样削减那2节体育课，还是削减2小时的数学课？即使你唯一关心的是数学成绩。情况可能是这样，这正是我们的发现。我们发现参与体育活动的学生的学业成绩实际上要好得多。所以最好腾出两个小时上数学，让他们到处跑跑再回来，这也可以用作激励，对吧？所以如果你，如果我告诉你，听着，把工作做完，你就可以出去打篮球了，
that could be used as incentives. So the kids will enjoy coming to school more and everything around it will become nicer. So I wouldn't be as pessimistic as we can't do anything, but we need to be very careful. Oury, when it comes to designing incentives, it's really important to pay attention to the size of the incentives that you're designing. Uvran studies looking at the risks of running incentives
这可以作为激励。所以孩子们会更喜欢上学，周围的一切也会变得更好。所以我不会像“我们什么也做不到”那样悲观，但我们需要非常小心。奥里，在设计激励措施时，真正重要的是要注意你所设计的激励措施的规模。乌夫兰的研究着眼于运营激励的风险
that are too small. Tell me about that work. So we had the same setup with the kids collecting money in these special donation days. And what we wanted to do is compare kids that are just motivated by, that's the right thing to do, you should go out and get it. With kids that get a small kickback. So we gave them, we offered them 1% of what they collected.
太小了。跟我讲讲那项工作。所以我们有和孩子们在这些特殊的捐赠日筹集资金相同的设置。我们想做的是，将仅仅受到“这是正确的事，你应该出去争取”激励的孩子们，与获得一点回扣的孩子们进行比较。所以我们给了他们，我们向他们提供他们筹集金额的1%作为奖励。
So if you collected $200, you got $2 as a reward, which is very little. And what we found was that when we offered this reward, these incentives, kids were much more likely to stay home and not go out to collect money. Because now they said, well, it's only $2. It's not worth it, right? I'm not going to put all this effort. So Aldo restockinian died, ran an experiment like that.
如果你筹集了200美元，你作为奖励会得到2美元，这非常少。我们发现，当我们提供这种奖励、这些激励时，孩子们更有可能呆在家裡，而不愿出去筹集资金。因为现在他们说，好吧，这只有2美元。不值得，对吧？我不会付出所有这些努力。所以 Aldo restockinian died 进行了一个这样的实验。
And the title I think is really revealing. We called it, pay enough or don't pay at all. So the point is that if you would have offered these kids $100, they would have collected all the money they can. But when you effort too little, you change the story before that the story was, I'm doing it because that's right thing to do. Now when you offer incentives, I'm doing it because I'm getting paid. Well, if I'm getting paid, pay me enough. Otherwise, don't pay me. You've also done some research that suggests that making an incentive too large can cause people to choke, especially on tasks involving cognitive capacity such as attention and memory.
我觉得这个标题很有启发性。我们称之为“付够薪水，否则一文不付”。关键是，如果你给这些孩子们提供100美元，他们会筹集所有能筹集到的钱。但当你付出的太少时，你改变了之前的故事：故事本是“我这样做是因为这是正确的事”。现在，当你提供激励时，变成了“我这样做是因为我拿了报酬”。好吧，如果我拿了报酬，那就付我足够的钱。否则，别付我。你还做了一些研究，表明让激励过大可能会导致人们发挥失常，尤其是在涉及认知能力（如注意力和记忆力）的任务上。
Can you tell us about the study you conducted looking at the effect of very large incentives on performance? So think about public speaking or imagine that I ask you to do, say, free shot in basketball. I don't know how good you are, maybe you'll do two out of 10. Now imagine that I'll pay you a million dollar if you'll be successful. Oh, boy.
你能跟我们讲讲你关于观察巨额激励对表现的影响的研究吗？所以想想公开演讲，或者想象我让你做，比如说，篮球罚球。我不知道你有多擅长，也许10个能进2个。现在想象一下，如果你成功了，我付给你一百万美元。哦，天哪。
Right, exactly. So things that you would have done automatically before that now you started thinking about it and turns out that in many cases, thinking about it is much less good than just doing it automatically. So just don't tell me that you'll give me a million dollars, I have a 20% chance of doing it. If you'll give me, if you'll offer me a million dollars, I probably, you know, be so far off because I'll be too excited. And that's basically what we found. We found it.
对，没错。所以以前你会自动完成的事情，现在你开始思考了，结果证明在很多情况下，思考远不如直接自动完成来得好。所以别告诉我你会给我一百万美元，我只有20%的成功几率。如果你给我，如果你向我提供一百万美元，我可能会，你知道的，差得十万八千里，因为我会太激动。这基本上就是我们的发现。我们发现了这一点。
In cases in which thinking is not what you need to do. You really need to follow your instinct and do the automatic things. People were less successful when we did this. They basically choked under pressure. You said that incentives can also be a powerful truth seeking device. They can reveal preferences that would otherwise remain hidden. I understand that some companies offer to pay employees to quit their jobs. Why would they do this, Uri?
在不需要思考的情况下。你真的需要顺从你的本能去做那些自动化的事情。当我们这样做时，人们反而不太成功。他们基本上在压力下发挥失常了。你说激励也可以成为一种强大的求真工具。它们可以揭示否则会被隐藏的偏好。我听说有些公司甚至出钱让员工辞职。尤里，他们为什么要这么做？
I love this. I teach negotiation and they tell my students that the only time that they should lie is when they're interviewed for a job, they need to show excitement. If you're not excited about the job, why would I hire you? But because of that, if I'm the employer, and I want to keep only the people that I really want to be there, because they're much more productive, but if I ask you, are you excited to work for me?
我太喜欢这个了。我教谈判，我告诉我的学生，他们唯一应该说谎的时候是在面试工作时，他们需要表现出兴奋。如果你对这份工作不兴奋，我为什么要雇用你？但正因为如此，如果我是雇主，我想留住那些我真正希望留在那里的人，因为他们的生产力要高得多，但如果我问你，你对为我工作感到兴奋吗？
You'll say, yes, of course. How can I actually use incentives to find out who really cares about me? Instead of asking, you are excited to work for me? I'll tell you, look, Shankar, here's $10,000 if you want to leave. You're welcome to leave. Thank you for working for with us. We are happy and good luck. Now if you're happy to work for me, you'll say no, no, no, no, 10,000, I don't want the $10,000. I'm happy over here. And if you are like on the margin and you're not sure, you'll just take the $10,000, we'll depart as friends,
你会说，是的，当然。我如何才能真正利用激励机制找出谁真正关心我？我不会问“你对为我工作感到兴奋吗？”，而是会告诉你，看，尚卡尔，如果你想离开，这里有1万美元。欢迎你离开。谢谢你和我们一起工作。我们很高兴，祝你好运。现在，如果你很高兴为我工作，你会说不，不，不，不，1万美元，我不要这1万美元。我在这里挺高兴的。而如果你处于边缘状态并且不确定，你就会拿走这1万美元，我们将作为朋友分道扬镳，
which is also important because otherwise, you can bed mouth me, you can sabotage. I don't want to fire you. So I can really select on the people that want to be with me in the company. And by the way, it could have other effects. So now, because I gave up $10,000, I really have to justify this. If I'll go to work
这也是很重要的，否则，你可能会说我的坏话，你可能会进行破坏。我不想解雇你。所以我真的可以挑选那些想和我一起留在公司的人。顺便说一句，它还可能产生其他影响。现在，因为我放弃了1万美元，我真的必须证明这是对的。如果我去上班
on Monday morning, now I really need to justify it. I really need to work hard in order to show that I was not stupid to give up the $10,000. So these people are going to be surprisingly even more motivated than they were before. It's interesting. So in some ways it's revealing what might actually be in people's hearts, including things that they might not know themselves. Once you're actually faced with an incentive, you might come to a different decision and that could actually reveal something not just to the company, but even to yourself. It's really amazing how little we understand our preferences in many cases. So very often, we get people that get a job offer and then they decline it.
在周一早上，现在我真的需要证明它是对的。我真的需要努力工作，以证明放弃1万美元并不愚蠢。所以这些人将出人意料地比以前更有动力。这很有趣。所以在某些方面，它揭示了人们内心的真实想法，甚至包括他们自己可能都不知道的事情。一旦你真正面临激励，你可能会做出不同的决定，这实际上不仅可以向公司揭示一些东西，甚至可以向你自己揭示。在许多情况下，我们对自己的偏好了解得如此之少，这真是太惊人了。所以很多时候，我们会遇到有人得到工作机会然后拒绝的情况。
And not because they needed a job offer to, in order to negotiate. But really because they thought, you know, they come to San Diego say, in my case, they come from a cold place. Now, it's very nice outside. They enjoy it. It's a vacation. They're really happy about this. They say, okay, we want to live in San Diego. Then they have the offer and they're starting, oh, we have to take our three little kids from school. That's going to be hard. Where are we going to leave? You know, they start thinking about the details and they discovered that they don't want it. So in many cases, we don't really know our preferences until we face the decision that we need to make. And we'd be paid to quit until you're offered $10,000. You might not even understand that you're not happy
并不是因为他们需要工作机会来谈判。而是因为他们真的以为，你知道的，他们来到圣迭戈，以我为例，他们来自一个寒冷的地方。现在，外面天气很好。他们很享受。这就像是一场度假。他们对此感到非常高兴。他们说，好吧，我们想住在圣迭戈。然后他们拿到了工作 offer，并开始想，“哦，我们得把三个小孩子从学校接走。这可不容易。我们要住在哪里？”你知道的，他们开始考虑细节，然后发现他们并不想要这个。所以在很多情况下，直到我们面临需要做出的决定之前，我们并不真正了解自己的偏好。而在你被提供10万美元之前，你甚至可能不明白你不快乐
where you are. You will not be very motivated. You will not be a good worker, but you want to understand why. You know, one of the things I've noticed as we've talked to are, is that when we've seen all the ways that incentives work and how they don't work, it seems to me that it's really important to run lots and lots of experiments. Because what works in one context might not work in another, what works at one point in time might not work in another, what works at one point in time, might not work in another, I'm really struck by how little such thinking shapes our efforts,
你所在的地方。你的动力不会很足，你也不会是一个好员工，但你想弄明白为什么。你知道，在与奥里交谈时我注意到的一件事是，当我们看到激励起作用的所有方式以及它们不起作用的方式时，在我看来，进行大量实验真的很重要。因为在一个语境下起作用的东西在另一个语境下可能不起作用，在一个时间点起作用的东西在另一个时间点可能不起作用，在一个时间点起作用的东西在另一个时间点可能不起作用，我深深地感到，这种思考对我们的努力产生了多么少的影响，
whether that's at the level of companies or the level of countries, so often managers and leaders tell themselves, I know what needs to be done. My political loyalty is tell me what's going to work. And especially, I think, when you feel like you're doing something important, something you care about, it's so easy to forget to question yourself, to doubt yourself. It's really, really hard to understand the importance of what you said. Think about culture. So I live in the US for 22 years now and I'm still surprised, very often, because they don't get the signal. So I learned that when American tells me let's do lunch, basically they
无论是公司层面还是国家层面，经理和领导者常常告诉自己，我知道需要做什么。我的政治忠诚会告诉我什么会起作用。特别是，当我觉得自己在做一件重要的事情、一件你在乎的事情时，太容易忘记质疑自己、怀疑自己。要理解你所说的话的重要性，真的、真的很难。想想文化。所以我已经在美国生活了22年，我还是经常感到惊讶，因为他们听不懂弦外之音。所以我了解到，当美国人告诉我“一起吃个午饭吧”，基本上他们
mean we don't want to see you again. Unless they say let's do lunch on Monday. In Israel, everyone is much more blunt. So you need to calibrate. And the same is true about incentives, and they doesn't have to be between different cultures. It could be cultures could be also taxi drivers versus teachers versus bankers in San Diego. And different people have different things that motivate them. I talk in the book, for example, about incentives to buy pre-use, to buy hybrid cars. This will not work on the guide that is driving the big pickup truck.
意思是“我们不想再见到你了”。除非他们说“周一一起吃个午饭吧”。在以色列，每个人都直言不讳得多。所以你需要校准。对于激励也是如此，而且不一定非得在不同文化之间。文化也可以是圣迭戈的出租车司机与老师与银行家之间的区别。不同的人有不同的激励因素。我在书中谈到了购买二手车、购买混合动力汽车的激励措施。这对于开着大皮卡的家伙不管用。
They don't care about the environment. They don't care about signaling that they care about the environment. You need to find the group that is really relevant for your incentives and find what works on them. So it's not that one size fits all. Different situations, different people, different cultures will require different things.
他们不在乎环境。他们不在乎发出他们关心环境的信号。你需要找到真正与你的激励相关的群体，并找出对他们起作用的方法。所以这不是一刀切的。不同的情况、不同的人、不同的文化会需要不同的东西。
And the way to do it is first to think about it, right? But then we try to see whether it works and then maybe you need to tweak it a bit and then maybe after you have it for a while, you see that people found a way to game it, so solve this problem. So it's a dynamic process that needs a lot of data in order to make sure that you're right. And especially I think in politics, I don't know if you'd agree with me, but I think in
而这样做的第一步是思考，对吧？但随后我们尝试看看它是否管用，然后也许你需要稍微调整一下，接着也许在你使用了一段时间后，你发现人们找到了钻空子的方法，从而解决这个问题。所以这是一个动态过程，需要大量数据来确保你是对的。尤其是，我认为在政治中，我不知道你是否同意我的观点，但我认为在
politics, this is often so not the case, right? If you think about so many of the political debates that we see around us, so many of them are basically saying, I'm right because of this ideology or I'm wrong, you're wrong because of that ideology. As opposed to saying we can actually run an experiment to figure this out. Let me ask you a question. Imagine that you have a big company and you invite two consultants.
政治中，往往根本不是这样，对吧？如果你想想我们周围看到的那么多政治辩论，其中许多基本上都在说，我是对的，因为这种意识形态；或者我是错的，你是错的，因为那种意识形态。而不是说我们实际上可以进行实验来弄清楚这一点。让我问你一个问题。想象一下，你有一家大公司，你邀请了两位顾问。
One of them tells you, I know the solution to your problem. Give me a million dollar and I solve your problem immediately, no problem, everything's good. And the other consultant tells you, I have no clue what's the right thing, but I can design a study that will tell you which one will you take, many people will take the first one. And I think you want your politician to know what's right.
其中一个告诉你，我知道你问题的解决方案。给我一百万美元，我马上帮你解决问题，没问题，一切都很好。而另一个顾问告诉你，我不知道什么是对的，但我可以设计一项研究来告诉你……你会选择哪一个？许多人会选择第一个。我想你会希望你的政治家知道什么是对的。
You don't want them to run experiments in order to find out. You elect them because you think that they are good at it. That's what they have to present. And that's why the entire culture of politics is not... Look, I'm good because they know how to run experiments and find out what's the right thing to do. No, I want a politician that knows what's the right thing to do. And I think that that's a mistake.
你不想让他们为了找出答案而进行实验。你选举他们是因为你认为他们擅长此道。这就是他们必须展现的。这就是为什么整个政治文化不是……听着，我很擅长，因为我知道如何进行实验并找出正确的事情要做。不，我想要一个知道正确事情该怎么做的政治家。我认为这是一个错误。
Urik Nisi is an economist at the University of California, San Diego. Uri, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It was a great pleasure. Thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
乌里克·尼西是加州大学圣迭戈分校的经济学家。尤里，非常感谢你今天来到《隐秘大脑》。非常荣幸。谢谢你。《隐秘大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·帕尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、赖恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。
I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For today's Anson Hero, we bring you a story from our sister's show, My Ansanhiro. The story comes from Sarah Feldman. In 2001, my hometown of Houston was hit by a tropical storm, and I was on vacation in Connecticut. We couldn't go home that day, of course, so my father decided to take me to the Bainiki Rare Book and Manchukip Library and Yale University. I was around 13 or 14 years old
我是《隐秘大脑》的执行主编。今天的“无名英雄”（Anson Hero），我们为你带来姐妹节目《我的无名英雄》中的一个故事。这个故事来自莎拉·费尔德曼。2001年，我的家乡休斯敦遭到热带风暴袭击，当时我在康涅狄格州度假。当然，我们那天无法回家，所以我父亲决定带我去耶鲁大学的拜尼克珍本与手稿图书馆。我当时大约13或14岁
and I was asking this gentleman named Bill Carver about a bunch of questions like how do you keep all these rare books okay and what's the oldest book you have and then I told him about how my grandparents went into my house that was flooded and all of my books lots of them because I was a big reader as a child were destroyed and he said to me Sarah I'm gonna send you a book in the mail so you can start your collection again and he did and I got a really nice book called the Medieval Book by Barbara A. Schaler. And I also received a letter in the mail. And I'd like to read it to you. December 8, 2001, Deer Sarah have often thought of you and your family and that terrible flood of 2000. He meant 2001. As promised, enclosed as a rather scholarly book,
我问一位名叫比尔·卡弗的先生一堆问题，比如你们是如何妥善保存这些珍贵书籍的？你们拥有的最古老的书是什么？然后我告诉他，我的祖父母去了我那被洪水淹没的房子，我的很多书——因为我小时候是个狂热的读者——都被毁了。他对我说：“莎拉，我要寄一本书给你，这样你就可以重新开始你的收藏了。”他真的这么做了。我收到了一本非常好的书，名叫芭芭拉·A·谢勒写的《中世纪的书》。我还收到了一封信。
which you may be slightly mature for your age, but I thought it might help you shape your new library collection. And as the years progress, this book may grow in stature and value to you. Have a happy holiday season. Wish you and loved ones all the best. Courgely, Bill Carver. I want to tell him that I'm 34 now and my life is great. I'm married. I have a dog and my partner and I like to visit cathedrals in Europe and go the Cloisters Museum in New York City from time to time and I'm obsessed with medieval art. I actually sent the library letter during the pandemic, but I never heard back. I'm not sure if he's alive still because he seemed old to me when I was 14 at the time, but I just love to tell Bill Carver
我想读给你听。“2001年12月8日，亲爱的莎拉：我经常想起你和你的家人，以及2000年那场可怕的洪水。”（他指的是2001年）。“如承诺的那样，信封里附上了一本相当学术的书，对你的年龄来说可能稍微成熟了一点，但我认为它可能有助于你塑造新的图书馆藏书。随着时间的推移，这本书的地位和价值对你而言可能会增长。祝你节日快乐。祝你和挚爱一切都好。真诚的，比尔·卡弗。”我想告诉他，我现在34岁了，我的生活很棒。我结婚了。我有一只狗，我和伴侣喜欢参观欧洲的大教堂，时不时去纽约市的修道院博物馆，我迷恋中世纪艺术。我在大流行期间确实给图书馆写过信，但一直没有回音。我不确定他是否还活着，因为当年我14岁时，他对我来说似乎已经很老了，但我真的很想告诉比尔·卡弗
that he changed my life. Sarah Feldman lives in New York City where she has her own jewelry business. If you liked today's episode, please be sure to share it with a few friends. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他改变了我的生活。莎拉·费尔德曼住在纽约市，在那里她拥有自己的珠宝业务。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请务必与几位朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。回头见。该剧集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。